you are not like another human being
you're a contrarian yeah for just the
sake of it so you hate everything you
argue about everything you have a
generally unpleasant disposition that
you bring with you everywhere okay by
allowing I think it's salty am I
laughing back at you sorry I don't walk
around bubbly because I don't have a
famous TV show where everybody around me
wipes my ass every five minutes for me
oh sorry I'm out there in the real world
and you're walking around with a group
of people going Sal is everything okay
that's such a team warm enough sound
that's two times in this episode for 20
minutes Hume
that you argued and shouted at my face
and then went okay so I'm wrong
I hate you feel so good